hello everyone uh it's my honor uh to
present like Dr Dr Marian she's a ni and
data science lead at tml and she'll talk
she'll talk about um a very hot and the
cool topic that deep fake thank you
doctor thank
you thanks a lot good afternoon everyone
and welcome to my talk um as um
mentioned my name is Maya miadi I am Ai
and data science lead at tml and um uh
my background is in AI I have a PhD in a
Aid planning and for quite number of
years I have applied AI to different
Industries but the last five years uh I
was working at in detecting Financial
crime and anti-money laundering and this
is where I um research deep fake and um
notice that deep fakes can be used to
steal identity and commit fraud today
I'm going to give you guys um um an
impression of deep fake hopefully and uh
we will start actually by definition of
the deep FS what are actually deep FS
the term defects is consists of two
terms deep learning and unfake and
simply put is actually synthetic data or
synthetic Medias where um uh person's
face has been swapped with another one
of course we can do this with different
things like also Photoshop but Ai and
machine learning can improve like have
like really strong deep fakes and uh
when you have a deep fake you can either
use it for positive side like
entertaining or to deceive and to uh
commit fraud as I said
today we are going to explore together
the following parts uh first we go like
how is deep defects are made this is
very I uh explain it a little bit on the
like software level hopefully after this
you will go to pick up the GitHub just
play around with the uh uh deep fake and
just make your own deep fake in the
second part we made deep fakes can we
improve it can we make it better
beautiful with more generative AIS and I
hope to give you an impression of what
are generative AI generative address
area on networks and my aim is that
after that part that you go and write
your own python code on the guns but
more of like understanding of what's
Happening under the hoood so a bit of
the science and intuition behind it as
well then we go to the good and the bad
is is like applications what what kind
of stuff can we can we do with it what
kind of effect has it and when I started
this I told actually it can be like used
completely misused for some purposes and
the last one is okay we have developed
the um the Deep
fake they are made with AI can we use AI
or other techniques to recognize them as
well okay let's start with making a deep
fake this is like a simp of deep fake if
you have the original one and you have a
face of three different peoples and you
want to swap uh with it as you can see
the the characteristics the the facial
characteristic of these people has been
like kind of swapped with each other and
it looks pretty
natural how can we do that and imitate
that actually there is um a
software and they call themselves an a
leading uh oport software at uh deep
fake uh I let it to you guys to judge
that but it is um and they have this
paper of of 2021 and all of the details
are there but you need some materials
and where do we have materials most of
the time from celebrities so let's take
Robert Downey Jr Elon Musk and we want
to swap their
faces the Deep learning technique that
they use is
autoencoder probably most of you guys
have heard of a auto encoder but if you
haven't is consists of two neuron
networks one of them is an encoder just
pick up the information of your input uh
features picture whatever that you have
as an input compress it to a latent
space and then com de compress it back
reconstructed back to its originals and
what kind of application can we think of
uh denoising a picture so just like
making it constructing it back but you
can also use that for for anomaly
detection because when you compress
things and they compress it back what
will be completely removed the anomalies
so this is actually where the
autoencoder has different um
applications but let's get back to our
making deep FES uh for making def FES
you need a picture so Elon Musk we need
a picture we encode
it get the base facial characteristic of
Elon Musk and when we use a decoder we
get back to its original so so far so
good but if we have two people or more
people uh what this uh Auto encoder does
is that it will just use one encoder for
all of the pictures but then uh each of
the people will have their own
decoders and if we want to make it deep
fake very small trick is that we use the
encoder for the original person but then
we swap actually the decoder and we can
then kind of combine the face
pces as every project in Ai and data
science you cannot go ahead and train
the model like uh just uh from the start
you need some some steps and most of the
time it's a lot of pre-processing so uh
putting it like very fast and like like
in a good flow is that you need about 10
minutes of video of both of
them then uh we start to extract images
and uh the frames should be about 600 to
2,000 for this specific software and
then when you have them you want
actually to each of the frames of the
heads you want to actually have like
kind of outlined mask of their face
because you want to replace that and how
better that mask has been defined how
better you can replace actually the the
the faces
together let me um oh yeah uh let's go
for for just a bit here is that then you
can use um Auto encoder and just go the
way that I explain it um if the faces
are too different if for example my face
has this shape and somebody has
completely different shape then we use a
little bit of image processing we use
morphing to just like kind of bring the
two faces together again the PO
pre-processing I was talking about and
merging means we apply our model to uh
to both of them to do the swap and after
that you still can do post-processing
for the eye color face uh like this skin
color and those kind of stuff let me
show it a little bit
visually okay extract the faces like uh
very important from the faces is that
every movement like the way that your
your face is moving you wouldn't notice
but actually is really different than
another person so it needs to capture so
if the video does not compare like it's
too too quiet then it will not be it
will not be a good video so 10 minutes
of video means 10 minutes of video
really moving around in that video then
uh we go and extract and identify the
mask the way I was explaining it Me
Maybe also need a little bit of more um
manually helping actually the neuron
Network
here then um we will follow actually the
heads or the mask in the in the faces
and now we can start to train and merge
that so if we let the software to go for
23 hours as you can see in the last
column nothing that much happened if the
original ones like the each of the faces
we reconstruct them they look they look
okay but when you combine we still see
Robert dowy Jr so let it a little bit um
like go for about 50 hours and that's
where we start to see actually the two
phases in the last column start to get
kind of
combined so this is the kind of the
results after 20 like 50 hours of course
you can let the software depends on how
much of patience you have uh for two
weeks or so and that's where it gets
better and better let me see if the GIF
is working yeah it's working so it is
actually as you can see if you have seen
Elon Musk he moves his whole body the
whole time to to the front and back and
this is actually Elon Musk in his
original thing but the face that is is
there is the face of uh Robert Downey Jr
so if you want to have fun uh just
combine actually the people that are
really are so different from each other
and you can see uh that and to do so
it's it's good to just uh visit this uh
GitHub I really like it then you can go
and look at the python
um all of the the the models and it's
like API uh programming so you just
really see what's happening there and
what kind of options they are using so
it's a a very cool one to to to to try
okay we build it but you guys saw it
wasn't that impressive it looked nice
but you could say this is like hacky
sketchy no it's not it's not that uh
that good although you can improve it
with more number of hours is still not
so good how can we improve it is with uh
generative adversary on
networks I promise you guys to just have
like a deep dive here on generative
adversary networks and what they are on
a very conceptual level it's like um if
you again have never worked with GES of
that they are contain uh like consist of
two parts again a little bit all like o
in order is like have two things the
generator and the discriminator and the
generator is this forger will create
Arts wants to create something and the
discriminator is the detective one the
one that actually wants to say you know
this is not good enough this is this is
is definitely a fake so this is the on
like on a very high level for us data
scientists let's go a little bit looking
at at the deeper level and that is that
where the um we have for generator noise
so
um gion distributed noise uh will feed
will be fit fed to generator I will
actually create a fake
image and then our discriminator which
has the real labels the real uh pictures
we put it together and we look and will
say is this actually fake or
real and because there are two new
networks back to back we can use that
loss function you know the back
propagation for both of
them and back propagate from
discriminator through the whole process
that that lost function and improved
both of them so it's not that our
detective is is better or our forgeries
better both of them get better at the
same
time it it's like they are kind of
playing this minan Max game and in in
that uh game uh basically it's like the
loss function of the two are combined
let me explain it with the paper from
um good fellow is actually the creator
of guns and um this is from 2004
important if you like it you can just go
deep dive do a deep dive there and this
is actually the the training loss don't
worry I will explain it's a little bit
of formula there but it is actually
where the generator wants to create a
very good image and the discriminator
want actually to uh say find actually if
this generated or real and this is where
we see that the uh we minimize actually
the loss for generator and maximize it
for the
discriminator let me
just show it on the picture a little bit
better is that we have that formula we
have the both of them so if we split
both of them you can see that which part
of so it uh the noise is just going so
the noise Z is going through uh the
generator generator look at the G of Z
and then D of G of Z becomes actually so
it's just not that difficult looking at
the formula or the loss function and for
a discriminator it's just the function
itself like the picture itself and then
we get get actually both of them bear
with me we are almost there and this is
like the the whole for the whole uh
algorithm so what what we do is that we
um we need to actually do do this like
play but but freezing one and then going
to another one so the first thing that
we do is we freeze our generator
whatever it is we we just don't don't
care about it's probably bad but we
don't don't care about we start to just
give the images completely randomly
chosen sample to the generator to to the
discriminator and it will learn actually
what's what's real versus what's fake
and then when the discriminator become
good we kind of freeze the weight and
then we will go to generator give them
some some completely different s uh
sample of noises and it will start
actually uh the the the discriminate use
the discriminator to just kind of
becoming better and better so this is in
a nutshell uh the generative adversary
or
network and this is the pictures that
they are making so basically they start
with something which is like make
absolutely no sense and it looks super
beautiful as you can see her skin her
hair everything looks completely natural
but this comes from the website this
person does not exist which is a website
created by Nvidia and every time you
refresh you get another another person
generated by the uh by the website
completely uh generated by gener
generative adversarial
Network you may ask like what is the
reason that actually the first um
pictures are
so um noisy and little and what's then
after that happening when you have um
like a very good picture
simply put is that we start with the
progress Progressive growing we start
with really really really badly uh
pictures and then we improve it so it's
just like almost pixels what we are
doing and if the the neuron Network gets
better in that then we go to because
otherwise you would not converge can you
can you converge from nothing to a very
perfect picture probably not so this is
also Progressive uh uh uh growing which
is combin with that whole formula that I
explained to you guys which is very
simply two neuron net for kind of
competing with each other then using it
with lower to very upper uh layers and
then you get actually good good
results um I would also suggest to go
there and just take a look at this
website as well there are variation a
lot of actually variation of cons and
I'm not going to like go one by one
which for each of them but the one of
them is like when you just give a text
this is a bird and it's having this like
a yellow thing and and and a black beak
and then we just like uh go and do it at
that's stack can you can also even
create like from a Monet to a picture is
like from the very cool software any
kind of art can be actually changed to a
picture but you even can just like be an
AR architecture just draw something I
will give you the real building for like
showing to your
customers but how can we make deep f is
with this one and this is style Gans a
style Gans is basically is what we have
just talking about like the growing and
everything but it just um creates this
um conditioning so you can see it's a
condition of all of these people their
hair eyes and everything will be mapped
and it will be combined and then you can
get actually all of these together to
something of whatever defect that you
want and the reason that it can do just
showing a very simple example if you
want to give some condition and it's we
want to say it's men or woman and you
want to have like a facial hair or not a
facial hair probably when you have woman
you do not have beard that much probably
uh so then you will have like this empty
part actually in the distribution of the
gion distribution but we make everything
from that gion distribution if you have
you have a you know hold there then you
have trouble in your convergence or
building anything and that's where uh
the style Gans just use mapping to just
improve that so that so that whatever
that your and I'm I'm just coming with
two things but we maybe can give them
like 10 different things about the skin
color and eye color and those kind of
stuff we will combine them together with
something which is like mapping or will
then give us the the the the better
mapping and the better convergence still
I want you guys to just remember that
base and on top of that base is just
things like kind of stacking up to get
that this is the part that um um you can
go and experiment with the style gu and
it's uh I think it archive insight
has in a Google collab a style gun and
you can just go one by one look at the
intuition you can go go look at the it
it it has all of the notebooks and
everything and building a deep fake I
think you I don't need to even explain
this is the same you go from data
collection training of the guns that go
find tuning and at the end it becomes
face alignment and mapping and we swap
and that's the reason that we get
actually quality start to get from bad
quality to one and this is where
probably you guys have seen this is a
deep fake of Morgan Freeman which is
definitely not Morgan Freeman this is
just completely generated by um the
company deep Network think uh and um it
has been the voice and everything has
been with the with the guy actually next
and you can see that he at the end of
the video he's just kind of showing that
it is him uh talking and not uh Morgan
Freeman
okay now we built our deep fakes what
are the good application that we can
have there as you guys can imagine we
can use it for satire and humor
education uh for um entertainment for
film industry but also make things
accessible make things nice
um I don't want to show you the video of
a lot of celebrities but I show you one
thing that is really it was like kind of
impressive to me and this is the video
of David Beckham talking about ending
malaria which is like a very um deadly
disease but talking in nine languages
what's actually so subtle about that he
starts with his beautiful British
English but then he will change to
Spanish and all of these languages but
then his face his expression the ve that
he talks Arabic or Chinese is is
actually all that country and that's
really important so uh so different than
when you when you are talking actually
uh when you're making a deep fake which
is like having a positive
effect and as I explained this is like
probably now for you guys completely
understandable way that your face mask
should be uh like from David beom should
be replaced by all of the people that
are speaking those nine
languages and for the that we we
basically have
um the problem is that it's just
undermined what's the effect undermining
our our trust it's uh it's just
manipulating the public opinion is
disinformation and the problem with that
is that we do not know anymore how to
trust and what what to trust anymore as
where for example the um United States
Congress says now is the the line
between the fact and a f fiction is so
blurry because everything that we it's
is also real we think is real like
really real and that's actually the the
problem when we had you know like was I
think three months the the the war
between uh the land the between the
Russia and and
U uh Ukraine we saw this deep fake video
from zalinsky which is say hey guys uh
just lay down your uh your uh weapon and
uh the the war is over and I want to
leave so you guys should leave as well
which is pretty convincing I would say
that moment when everybody's like
underground it didn't look like like the
best uh deep fake ever but it was still
really effective to just create so much
of chaos and on on a very high level so
that's actually the Deep effect of deep
fake and we do not need even to have
like this material you do do you
remember I said that we we need like 10
minutes no not anymore because like
papers like this one the force or Force
order motion is that that we just use
one picture and it's pre-trained on
anybody else like all of the humans on
Earth and it's just uh also take a look
at the the the paper and the kop this is
also very nice one is that uh you just
can give your own uh picture or picture
of anybody else use your own uh webcam
and in few minutes you will have
a a deep fake when you are talking
online on a zoom or or um or a team
talk so you just can actually do all of
these movements and the scary is that it
would predict like the mask and you it
can just put it in every lighting so not
even the lighting is a matter that like
okay it looks like different in that
lighting and after that we even have uh
animation if you guys proba probably
anybody in gaming is anybody in gaming
they will probably know the unreal
unreal engine which is like one of the
one of the people um like one of the
best companies there and they are um uh
basically um
creating almost real films that you can
so even do not use uh need to use any of
that I think this part I for you guys is
completely understand what we we want to
speculate on the future of De fake of
course the entertainment and stuff is
really good but the problem is the
Privacy when you just or or the security
or the chaos that we have so the the the
red area is where we really want to
actually have
um uh more emphasize on
it can we recognize deep
fakes we have a bunch of things that is
like in a foreign es analysis like
facial inconsistency you can see it and
audio inconsistency stuff that are
pretty uh good with good analysis you
can find it or metadata so when has been
recorded you know the form has been
recorded those kind of stuff but we can
also use AI so if we look at the
forensic we have this professor from uh
Berkeley the UC Berkeley and uh he has
also really good stuff on on uh follow
him he will always like post things on
on uh deep fake if you like deep fake
and he will show and he's like this he's
playing this uh ma mouse and Cat game uh
every time something appear with his
whole team from Berkeley he tries
actually to solve it but the problem is
that you always always one step behind
the
criminals but I personally like this one
you know the the the the people that are
actually having
um their heart like the heart patients
that having their their heart actually
measured they never do it anymore with
that nasty things that on their skin
they do it with the app which look at
their heart pumping to their face face
and the the color of the face start to
get all of these flushes the the red
flushes that comes it's like very micro
changes in the color I will then measure
your heart rate but the same time can be
used for a human being and a deep fake
because a human being will have blood
flushing to their face but a deep fake
not so it's really easy to use that next
to deep neuron Network and then actually
have pretty good results this is has
been like productionize by uh Intel and
they say
96% uh and BBC was looking at it so the
96% was a little bit as a third party
was a little bit lower but the it's one
of the best fake deep fake detectors out
there I'm not going to bother you guys
with all of the companies because it's
just like kind of a lot of black boxes
there that you you can take a look at
one thing that has come to mind is the
uh blockchain they use technology of
blockchain to just have uh actually the
data secure so it's not deep faked
actually
there so we are coming to the end of
presentation I show you you guys how the
FES are
made can we improve them a little bit we
could improve them a little bit with the
Gans and and and hopefully you got also
an impression of how Gans are are the
good and the bad of deep fakes and
finally can we recognize them yeah with
PPG we can we can make some uh some
steps thank you so
much